[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu 14 85 köpfe fünf meinungen wir
möchten unsere heutigen sendung über die
außenpolitischen themen sprechen die uns
alle bewegen putins krieg die
flüchtlingsströme die einrichtungs
beziehungen pflicht und die frage wie
ich sein kann dass es am donnerstag im
bundestag die erste beratung der anträge
zum thema impfpflicht gibt sie haben
richtig gehört die impfpflicht die fast
keiner mehr will und mit ihr auch
eigentlich keiner mehr reden will ist
immer noch nicht vom tisch wie kann das
sein meine gäste heute abend der
ehemalige regierung spricht sprecher und
deutschlands kommunikationsprofi nummer
eins béla anda neben ihm cdu-politiker
und kanzler der herzen wolfgang bosbach
an meiner seite wie jeden abend der
stellvertretende bild chefredakteur und
acht host ihr unseren live aus kiew
zugeschaltet ist laut balanceboard nun
links der chef der bild
parlamentsredaktion ralf schüler das
konzept der sendung ist sehr einfach
jeder von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht
was ihn bewegt schockiert gaga ihr
freund oder ob er einfach mal mit
anderen menschen diskutieren möchte
heute gibt es sogar ein spezial denn
nach der pause bis zur pause werden die
ukraine und russland machen und danach
wird es einen wechsel geben ronzheimer
wird die sendung verlassen und dr paul
brandenburg kommt rein um über die
impfpflicht zu sprechen heute also sogar
mal sechs köpfe sechs meinung aber
lassen sie uns doch jetzt direkt wie
gewohnt paul ronzheimer in kiel starten
er ist live vor ort und dem thema das
ihn heute bewegt
janina vielen dank und vielen dank dass
ich jeden abend hier aus kiew berichten
darf über meine gefühlslage aber
natürlich vor allem für die gefühlslage
der ukraine und wenn ich mir diesen tag
heute anschaut dann bin ich schockiert
habe aber gleichzeitig hoffnung ich
möchte damit beginnen was mich heute
schockiert hat und was mich zutiefst
traurig macht erneut sind journalisten
kollegen von mir ums leben gekommen
darunter ein mann ledig gut kannte wie
er sein name ralf kameramann für fox
news wir sind uns in afghanistan
begegnet wir sind uns hier in der
ukraine eigentlich jeden morgen begegnet
denn an dem ort an dem ich bin da war er
auch er bis er vor einem tag von einer
moerser von mörserbeschuss getötet wurde
neben ihm eine ukrainische kollegin
alexander ebenfalls getötet die angriffe
auf journalisten nehmen massiv zu
bereits drei getötete journalisten und
mehrere verletzte das zeigt erneut wie
wenig rücksicht wladimir putin auf
irgend ein menschliches leben auf irgend
ein ziviles leben nimmt auch mehrere
hochhäuser wohnblöcke wurden heute
morgen wieder attackiert das was mir
hoffnung macht und sehr viel respekt
abverlangt das sind die drei
regierungschefs die heute nach kiew
gereist sind unter anderem der polnische
ministerpräsident morawski und seine
kollegen was sie machen das hätte
eigentlich auch olaf scholz längst tun
müssen emanuel mag rowlings tun müssen
hier nach kiew zu fahren und wirklich
die solidarität ausdrücken zu zeigen
dass man bei den menschen ist und nicht
nur in brüssel oder berlin sagen dass
man bei den ukrainern steht nein diese
aktion mit einem zug hier einzureisen in
einer höchst gefährlichen situation das
verlangt mir wahnsinnig viel respekt ab
und das gibt mir hoffnung dass es
hoffnung für die ukraine gibt
pauli sehr bewegendes war gerade auch
bewegende stelle selbst wahrscheinlich
im studio es tut mir unfassbar leitbild
journalisten kollegen die du gerade
genannt hast für die familien und wir
denken auch hier an sie in berlin ich
würde jetzt übergang kann gar nicht gut
gewählt werden in dem zusammenhang danke
dass du ihn gedenkt hast und ich würde
jetzt einmal zu herrn bosbach schalten
und in die frage stellen sollte er stolz
nach kiew reisen herr bosbach sollte
unser bundeskanzler sich jetzt auf den
weg nach kef begeben um ein zeichen zu
setzen
so paul ronzheimer hat gerade den
richtigen begriff genannt es ist ein
zeichen es ist ein symbol aber das
sollte man auch nicht zu gering schätzen
es ist ja das zeichen der solidarität
und es ist schon ein unterschied ob man
das aus der ferne bekundet die
solidarität zu einem land zu einem
geschundenen volk oder ob man selbst vor
ort gemeinsam mit anderen kollegen
mit der regierung in kiew spricht das
nicht nur ein zeichen der solidarität
ist auch ein zeichen des persönlichen
mutes aber ich maße mir nicht an aus der
ferne den bundeskanzler zu empfehlen
nach kiew zu reisen ich glaube es wäre
auch nicht klug wenn er ganz allein da
hinfahren würde weil dann möglicherweise
sich jeder andere rechtfertigen muss
warum er dennoch nicht da hingefahren
ist wenn es der gemeinsame wille von
mehreren regierungschefs ist oder wäre
dann wäre olaf scholz gut beraten sich
diesem kreis anzuschließen aber ich
möchte von hier aus das ist in meinen
augen etwas überheblich olaf scholz
nicht sagen dass er nach kiew zu reisen
hat also ich bin da auch etwas
zwiegespalten ich finde es eine
wunderbare geste die im übrigen auch
unterstreicht wie nahe sich die
osteuropäischen länder sind was ja in
westeuropa oft vergessen wird die
geschichten der anrainerländer der
ukraine sind aufs tiefste verflochten
das habsburgerreich reichte natürlich
bis nach lemberg und cherno witz und
litauen reichte weite teile bis zur
ukraine und polen war ein teil litauens
und der ukraine die geschichten sind
verflochten die menschen sind
verflochten was wir gerne übersehen ist
dass diese länder alle eigentlich schon
in sich vielvölker staaten sind und wir
haben dann immer so ein bisschen die
herablassende kommentierung gehabt wenn
sie sich geweigert haben in brüssel
irgendwelche quoten zu akzeptieren dass
andere was mich etwas zwiespältig auf
den besuch gucken lässt wenn das zur
regel wird das staatsmänner der des
höchsten formats gewissermaßen
menschliche schutzschilde abgeben geben
wir putin ziele in die hand die auf
einen schlag regierungen kopflos machen
könnten und ob ich ihm das gerne da bin
ich doch sehr im zweifel
weil für sie seien sehr gefährlicher
besuch da stimme ich dir absolut zu
und vielleicht paul auch an dieser
stelle
war es der in vielen krisengebieten du
bist ein kriegsreporter der
egal ob man vor sechs sieben jahren war
und da die ganzen unruhen miterlebt hat
auch die kriegerischen
auseinandersetzungen die es da in
anderer form aber auch schon natürlich
mit gefahr gab du warst in afghanistan
hat der gefahr der taliban in die augen
geblickt war es den ägypten und wir
haben früher auch viel gesprochen in
dieser zeit
glaube jeder jeder kriegsreporter nimmt
ganz ganz besondere risiken auf sich
gerade auch in dieser zeit sind wir
wieder mit tödlichen gefahren die er
sich aussetzt um sein publikum den
menschen der öffentlichkeit eben
darzulegen darzustellen
was vor ort passiert ich hoffe
dass das das leid der familien in
irgendeiner weise
ertrag war ist es ja nie gemindert
werden kann es auch nicht sein aber dass
du auch vorsichtig bist und walten lässt
und in dieser phase auch nicht nur an
die großartigen geschichten für die user
und für die tanne leserinnen und leser
denkt sondern auch ein bisschen an dich
selbst in
wenn man so auf dem erfolgreich auch
berichtet hat und dem hagel gestanden
hat dann ist die gefahr groß dass man
die gefahr manchmal nicht so einschätzt
wie sieht dann eben täglich für dich ist
und deswegen alles alles gute und ich
und natürlich auch den da können wir
endlich einen freund getroffen sind
zudem besuchen das ist natürlich ein
starkes signal der drei und ich glaube
es ist der tschechische
ministerpräsident fiala der ja gesagt
hat wir kommen hier nicht einfach so
daher mit leeren händen sondern wir
bringen ein großes paket der eu mit ich
konnte noch nicht nachlesen ob jetzt
berichtet dort ist er bekannt geworden
ist was dieses paket nun beinhaltet aber
natürlich setzen und der bin ich bei
ralf auch die sich gefahren aus die
wenig zu kontrollieren sind
ob scholz dahin gefahren wäre besser ich
weiß nicht ob er dann sinn gehabt hätte
aber man kann sicherlich
eu-ratspräsident amtierender da wäre es
natürlich schön ein paar initiativen
mehr zu sehen als nur telefonate die
kein ergebnis haben aber wir werden
sehen was dieser besuch bringt und
welche ergebnisse er ja nach sich zieht
paul du wolltest gerade schon einsteigen
wenn ich es richtig gespürt habe hinter
mehr
nein aber ich bin ich verstehe schon die
argumentation was natürlich die gefahr
mit sich bringt auch für regierungschefs
wobei mein gefühl wäre dass wladimir
putin
doch davor
putin weiß man nicht aber dass er doch
davor einen regierungschef hier zu töten
zurückschrecken würde es gab ja noch
eine weitere initiative die in dem
zusammenhang interessant ist im vitali
klitschko der kiewer bürgermeister hatte
gefordert dass der papst und weitere
religiöse anführer nachkommen sollten
dem papst liegt dieser brief vor auch
das fand ich eine spannende initiative
lenkt jetzt ein bisschen ab von der
frage ob die eu genug macht ich finde
dass man in deutschland langsam sieht
dass deutschland sich erneut sperrt also
was ich höre aus brüssel ist das erneute
wut darüber gibt dass deutschland sich
so zurückhaltend verhält zu weiteren
sanktionen dass man sich weiter wehrt
auch gegen bestimmte sanktionslisten
gegen bestimmte namen und das ist doch
was hier in der ukraine für schweres
unverständnis sorgt
ja das ist eine schwierige debatte auch
auf der europäischen ebene wird ja über
härtere sanktionen
gestritten und wir sind jetzt in der
position wo die abhängigkeit die merkel
immer wieder vorgeworfen ist und warum
warum so kritische nachfragen gab bei
den nord stream zwei behandlungen und
bei ihrer politik wo diese abhängigkeit
sich tatsächlich in schmerzhafte
einschnitte ummünzt und das ist
natürlich ein problem
was man so ein patient der dem arzt
schaden will indem man seinen tropf
rauszieht
ist zweifellos mutig aber
möglicherweise am ende auch krank oder
tod und diese debatte ist nicht einfach
zu führen das sind tatsächlich die
folgen einer massiven abhängigkeit der
lebensader einer industrienationen
nämlich bei der energie ich erinnere
mich an abend dabei hat sie die
übertragen wo mir der amtierende
damalige wirtschaftsminister ganz klar
am rande der veranstaltung gesagt hat
vergesst diese autarkie diese
souveränität brauchen wir nicht im neuen
jahrhundert beziehen wir energie jeder
von jedem und das ist alles von gestern
das sind die gefährlichen illusionen für
die wir jetzt bezahlen und für die vor
allem die ukraine bezahlt das ist extrem
bitter ich tue mich nur mit einfachen
lösungen da immer schwer wenn wir nicht
aufpassen droht putin den gashahn zu und
sagten mal werden wir wollen mal gucken
ob ich länger ohne euer geld leben kann
oder länger ohne mein gas ich weiß nicht
wie das ausgeht er passt hier die frage
haben sie bevor sie zu ihrem thema
kommen war die energiewende falsch von
der union
also wir fangen nur mal eben vorne an
ich bitte an ronzheimer um verständnis
für meine zurückhaltung denn paul
ronzheimer selber geht hohes
persönliches risiko ein ich sitze hier
in ergolding bei münchen im warmen ich
setze mich überhaupt keinem risiko aus
und soll dann anderen empfehlen nach ihr
zu reisen damit tue ich mich schwer zum
thema weitere sanktionen ich möchte
einmal gerne wissen ob die sanktionen
die schon beschlossen worden sind
tatsächlich bei uns in deutschland alle
exekutiert worden sind wir sperrt
eigentlich die konnten was habe ich
davon wenn in brüssel oder bei
eu-gipfeln wo auch immer
kontensperrungen beschlossen werden wenn
die flugzeuge organischen am boden
bleiben sollen wenn vermögenswerte
beschlagnahmt werden sonne oder gesperrt
werden sollen wenn gar nicht klar ist
wer eigentlich dafür zuständig ist diese
beschlüsse auch durchzusetzen wir
sollten erstmal mit der exekution
bereits getroffene beschlüsse anfangen
wer ist eigentlich zuständig der bund
die länder erwartet man darauf dass die
banken das von sich aus machen das würde
ich alles mal gerne wissen ob das schon
eins zu eins durchgesetzt worden ist und
bei neuen sanktionen ich möchte ich
gerne wissen wie es danach weitergeht
woher beziehen wir öl oder gas in
welchen mengen sind die liefermengen
gesichert und zu welchen preisen und
welche auswirkungen hat das ich glaube
viele sind bereit auch schmerzliche
einschnitte hinzunehmen wenn das das
leid der menschen in der ukraine linda
aber es gibt auch viele die fragen wie
geht es denn danach weiter die
energiewende
wir hatten ja auch mal unsere regierung
angela merkel zunächst eine
laufzeitverlängerung des atomausstieges
der beschlossen worden ist unter der
regierung gerhard schröder dann kann das
unglück in fukushima dann kam der
ausstieg bis ende 2022 drei
reaktoren sind noch am netz und dann kam
das thema co2 vermeidung jetzt sind wir
dabei aus der kohleverstromung
auszusteigen
jetzt gehen wir noch mal zurück auf die
debatte nach fukushima ich bin sehr
sicher hätten wir damals die debatten
lage von heute gehabt dann hätten wir
eher den ausstieg aus der
kohleverstromung beschlossen wegen co2
reduktion als der ausstieg aus der
atomenergie man darf sich das nicht so
vorstellen dass man die reaktoren die
drei die jetzt noch in betrieb sind ein-
und ausschalten kann wer das licht im
büro das kann man nicht dass ein höchst
komplexer vorgang technisch und
rechtlich
ich mache ohnehin an die energiewende
ein fragezeichen das führt aber jetzt zu
weit weil es um die grundlastfähigkeit
geht wir haben weder permanent wind noch
haben wir permanent sonne und wir
brauchen eine sichere und saubere
energieversorgung unabhängig von
witterungseinflüssen wir werden
weiterhin strom sowohl aus
kernkraftwerke als auch aus
kohlekraftwerken importieren müssen ton
aber so als wäre das nicht der fall und
das ist das problem was ich sehe und ich
sage ihnen drei vier jahren werden wir
eine ganz andere debatte haben als heute
haben wir das realistischer betrachtung
herr bosbach wir bleiben bei der
realpolitik und bleiben doch direkt mal
bei ihrer these sie heute mitgebracht
haben weil nicht nur die energie werde
zwar in den nächsten jahren sehr
beschäftigen in diesem land
eine große bitte ist lasst die kommunen
diesmal nicht alleine wir haben enorme
fluchtbewegungen auch wenn jetzt noch
500.000 oder über eine million in die
unmittelbaren nachbarstaaten der ukraine
über führungen sind nahm in deutschland
schon etwa
150.000 flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
aufgenommen und es werden täglich mehr
die registrierung die erteilung eines
augen tanzen
da geht es um die anwendung der massen
zustroms richtlinie der europäischen
union und auch fleißig er auflegte heißt
tatsächlich so das ist die eine seite
aber die unterbringung vor ort die
sicherung des lebensunterhaltes wenn die
medizinische versorgung die erfüllung
der schulpflicht bei den kindern ist
eine mammut aufgabe für die kommunen
aber es ist eine gesamtstaatliche
aufgabe und hier dürfen wir die kommunen
nicht über gebühr belasten muss rasch
klarheit herrschen beim bund wird bei
den ländern wie die kommunen an diesen
an dieser stelle geholfen werden kann
und ein herzliches dankeschön für das
überragende
gesellschaftliche engagement bei der
aufnahme der flüchtlinge ist die not am
größten kommen die besten eigenschaften
von den menschen zum vorschein
ja ich bewundere ein bisschen wie ruhig
und sachlich und natürlich hat er völlig
recht wolfgang bosbach dass vorträgt
wenn man sich daran erinnert dass damals
uns erzählt worden ist dort kämen frauen
und kinder aus den kriegsgebieten den
wahrheit kamen 90 prozent junge männer
und zwar nicht nur aus den
kriegsgebieten wenn wir damals
kommentiert haben wir brauchen jetzt die
empathie der menschen und die
solidarität und wenn in den wirklichen
krisen wirklich betroffene kommen dann
sind die kapazitäten knapp das ist alles
eingetreten und man muss jetzt
tatsächlich sehen dass diejenigen die
migration immer als eine art
heiligenschein als eine art
glücksbringer für die gesellschaft
gefeiert haben nehmen sie claudia roth
nehmen wir die
migrations euphoriker von der spd die
sitzen jetzt da in verantwortlichen
ämtern in der bundesregierung vg hier in
berlin und die organisation schleift das
also man wirklich nur
fassungslos dabei stehen kann da gibt es
radio aufrufe dass man sich familien aus
der ukraine am bahnhof abholen kann wenn
man sie beherbergen will es gibt erste
fälle wo in hamburg familien wieder
zurückgegeben worden als mal mitbekommen
hat dass es kein geld dafür gibt das ist
haarsträubend man muss registrieren man
muss kontrollieren wir haben
drittstaatler darunter von denen nicht
ganz klar ist ob sie nicht zu hause
eigentlich schutz suchen müssten wir
müssen die kinder betreuen wir müssen
natürlich wissen wo wer ist wo es geld
braucht wo kinderbetreuung wichtig ist
wo es auch psychologische betreuung
braucht wenn man aus so einem
kriegsgebiet braucht dafür muss man
registrierungen haben und zwar ein sehr
ein geschlossenes system ich habe mit
pfarrer siggelkow gesprochen in dem
gründer der arche der sagte es ist
diesmal schlimmer als 20 15 und das kann
eigentlich nicht sein deutschland ist
ein hoch industrialisiertes land mit
einem riesigen verwaltung das muss
funktionieren wenn man sich anguckt wie
bravourös polen das leistet jeder der
dort ankommt bekommt das angebot eine
sim karte mit mit einem guthaben darauf
zu bekommen natürlich gegen
registrierungen er wird registriert wenn
er einreist er wird registriert wenn er
in einer aufnahme kommt und wenn er dort
wieder die verlässt wird er auch
registriert alles völlig unproblematisch
führt dazu dass man einen hohen
logistischen
sachverstand dort einsetzt der in
deutschland nicht erkennbar ist und die
bundesregierung hat nach wie vor keinen
plan und noch nicht mal ein
krisenzentrum das kann so nicht sein
weil ich war gerade so ein bisschen
überrascht weil ich komme gerade vom
berliner hauptbahnhof und das ist ja ich
meine wir werden jetzt in den letzten
tagen als berliner da gewesen sein und
das ist wirklich unglaublich was da an
hilfe organisiert ist da steht zum
beispiel eine riesen truck von einem
privaten telefonanbieter denn diese sim
karten dann erwähnt hast auch hier aus
gibt aber das sind private initiativen
von menschen die da sehen wir sind
private hilfsorganisationen rotes kreuz
von steiger stiftung viele andere machen
ja damit helfen eben auch vor ort oder
menschen sind ja sehr früh eben an den
bahnhof gegangen hier in berlin und
menschen mit mit karten und pappkarten
abzuholen zu sagen ob ein zimmer frei
man kann froh sein sich dass der große
flüchtlings track 2015 in münchen
ankommen und nicht in berlin denn da war
das wenigstens auch organisiert hier
verstehe ich auch nicht war man
vorbereitet hier ist das totale chaos
ausgebrochen
und man kann nur hoffen dass herr
bosbach gehört findet das natürlich
staatliche stellen hier aktiv werden und
diesen track der ja noch zunehmen wird
wir werden ja noch weitere
hunderttausende wahrscheinlich bekommen
ein flüchtling hier irgendwo dann auch
tatsächlich gesteuert wird ich habe nur
gehört dass in hannover bei hannover ja
ein verteilungszentrum ist also da
scheint das zu funktionieren aber hier
in berlin ist hier wirklich eine große
krise ausgebrochen
ein punkt über den man nicht reden darf
aber wir vielleicht wir sind ja ein
offenes gremium trotz mal reden sollte
ist dass es natürlich vielleicht auch
von innen die reaktionen der menschen
wenn sie denn passiert wieder annehmen
nicht zurück gehen sofern die zustände
ist irgendwann mal vor zu lassen
wenn das die sich integration
wahrscheinlich leichter werden wird als
2015 bei sie uns kulturell das muss man
einmal sagen näher sind als all die die
2015 zu uns gestoßen sind wenn auch aus
bürgerkriegs gründen
in viele ort herr bosbach wenn man jetzt
hier auch bela anda zu hat auch mit
blick auf 2015 haben wir beziehungsweise
und ich hier auch die politik vergessen
unsere hausaufgaben zu machen hätte man
jetzt besser vorbereitet sein müssen
wir waren darum geht es ja am ersten
wochenende september
überrascht wir können jetzt nicht
überrascht sein weil ja die entwicklung
in der ukraine vielleicht nicht im
detail aber doch in ihren auswirkungen
absehbar war und machen wir uns bitte
nichts vorher schüler auch das gehört zu
der wahrheit mann konnte erst über die
probleme die diese migrationsströme
witzig gebracht haben offen reden nach
der kölner silvesternacht kehren und ich
weiß ich weiß dass die bundesregierung
die schließung der balkanroute
kritisiert hat aber doch froh war dass
die balkanroute tatsächlich geschlossen
wurde weil danach auch durch das
abkommen mit der türkei die zahlen
erprobt und deutlich zurückgegangen sind
im moment können wir das nicht
feststellen die zahlen werden eher
steigen und ich ahne was kommt der bund
wird erklären wir sind für die
registrierung zuständig das macht das
dampfen vorläufigen aufenthaltstitels
schutzstatus wahrscheinlich subsidiärer
schutz die länder werden sagen die
unterbringung muss aber bei den bei den
kommunen erfolgen das geht nur vor ort
das kann ich in den landeshauptstädten
geregelt wird dass genau das was die
leute in unserem land nicht hören wollen
deswegen bildet bitte einen krisenstab
was für corona möglich ist das muss auch
für die flüchtlinge möglich sein bund
länder und gemeinden gemeinsam an einem
tisch sitzen die verteilung nach dem
büro und königssteiner schlüssel ja die
ist schnell getroffen aber die
verteilung ist doch erst der anfang
aller bemühungen vor ort das können
unsere kommunen nicht alleine stemmen da
brauchen sie hilfe des bundes
unterländer er beende das thema von
ihnen herr bosbach mit ihrem aufruf für
eine flüchtlings plan für die kommunen
und gehen weiterhin bleiben nicht bei
flüchtlingen wir gehen weiter zu
beleidigen apulien und legen los mit
herr schuler ja ich bin tatsächlich im
zuge der ukraine krise häufig gefragt
worden ich bin mit merkel ja häufig dort
gewesen wir haben auch gemeinsame
auftritte von merkel und putin
beobachtet ist der irre er sieht
aufgedunsen aber es ist ja physisch
angeschlagen was sein vorgehen erklären
sollte ist er mental nicht auf der höhe
oder fertigt aus usw die einfache
antwort ist nein
manfred lütz der große publizist hat man
ein gutes buch geschrieben irre wir
sperren die falschen 1 in den in der
psychiatrie sitzen die ihnen die
depressionen haben die große probleme
haben die andere verletzen würden kleine
fische im vergleich zu den diktatoren
der zeitgeschichte stalin und hitler hat
man auch immer gefragt sind die irre
nein sie sind nicht ihre sie sind auf
eine teuflische art und weise
intelligent und genial das sieht man an
dem kalten strategischen vorgehen von
putin ich würde ihn nicht dämonisieren
das ganze hat ein fast schon
folgerichtige szenario wir müssen uns
klarmachen im vergangenen sommer als der
besten hals über kopf aus afghanistan
abziehen konnte alle welt sehen der
westen ist nicht einmal in der lage eine
stammesgesellschaft in einem fiat welt
land irgendwie unter kontrolle zu halten
wenig später gab es die wahl in
deutschland mit einem klaren sieg für
die ampel koalition und für putin der
den westen und seinen dekadenten
lebensstil verachtet war das das signal
eines der wichtigsten länder in zentral
europa hat eine regierung mit einem
hohen idealistischen regierungsanteil
den grünen und sozialdemokraten was von
der fdp hält
weiß man so genau nicht und an der
stelle begann die aufrüstung an den
grenzen der ukraine
es war ganz klar und dass wir testen
würde wie stark ist dieser westen her
war in afghanistan schwach zeigt jetzt
regierungsbildung in deutschland neben
frankreich der 110 zentralmacht
frankreich ist gerade in den wahlen wie
stark ist dieser westen der in
sonntagsreden gern behauptet europa
müsse geostrategisch an gewicht gewinnen
ist dann aber am ende doch wegen
zerstrittenheit mannschaft genau das
fordert er heraus dass testet er denn
putin weiß ganz genau seine stärke an
der weltgeschichte ist nur zusichern
wenn er so ein gerät ins geschehen das
haben wir in syrien gesehen dass die
anderen sich an ihm abarbeiten müssen
dass man an ihm nicht vorbei kommt dass
er vielleicht der böse bube ist aber
allein kommt man halt nicht vorbei
wirtschaftlich kann in den westen nicht
nieder konkurrieren wirtschaftlich ist
china stärker er testet den westen
einfach auf eine schulhof
rabauken art er haut einfach mal einen
nachbarn rein dann gibt es natürlich
noch diese tatsächlich nicht zu
unterschätzende historische komponente
all das kommt bei ihm zusammen es ist
alles sehr rational man kann nicht sagen
dass er blind tätigt einschlägt und auch
seine strategie die wir jetzt gern
belächelt ist nicht ganz schlecht er hat
nicht die mittel das land zu überrennen
er versucht es nicht mehr lebenswert zu
machen zu entvölkern
die menschen dort so lange zu quälen wie
sie selbst flüchten und her das land
lehrer übernehmen kann das alles folgt
einer strategie bitte unterschätzen wir
putin nicht
herr bosbach ist der vergleich dass
putin ein irrer ist und ja auch der
selber in einem satz genannt wie hitler
ist es übertrieben oder es putin ein
diktator nein
ich glaube ist ein diktator ein despot
er war noch nie ein lupenreiner demokrat
er war immer schon ein lupenreiner
despot aber das heißt doch nicht also
folgt ist manfred lutz ist das richtige
stichwort ich hatte genau vor einer
woche die gelegenheit mit ihm mit
manfred wirtz psychiater und bestseller
autor überhaupt eine putin zu sprechen
im rahmen unseres podcasts ist die
wochen tester und originalzitat manfred
lütz er ist schrecklich normal
er hat das was jetzt geschieht über
jahre hinweg strategisch geplant und
vorbereitet und diese gleichung machen
wir sehr oft auf wir sagen es passiert
etwas unbegreifliches etwas
unmenschliches der muss ja verrückt sein
nein sagt er mit realschule oder
rollschuhen damit manfred lässt der ist
nicht verrückt da ist völlig ist völlig
normal dass die banalität des bösen und
dann kam noch der satz kann ich mich
noch gut erinnern
hütet euch vor den normen an
paul herr bosbach hat gerade noch mal
festgestellt wladimir putin ist kein
lupenreiner demokrat und wie gehen wir
denn jetzt um mit einem menschen wie
wladimir putin mit einem menschen der so
tickt und werbung schlag gesagt hat der
ist ja eigentlich alle strategisch
geplant hat langer hand
ja ich gebe
wolfgang bosbach und ralf schuler recht
in dem sinne dass wir schwach waren und
dass er das geplant hat aber ob das
jetzt wirklich strategisch so genial
geplant war da habe ich doch meine
zweifel wenn wir uns die
geheimdienstberichte anschauen und
wladimir putin vor hatte innerhalb von
tagen vielleicht hier in diesem zimmer
zu sitzen wo ich gerade sitze in kiew
und seinen sieg zu verkünden eine hätte
sich wahrscheinlich was pompöses
vorgestellt aber es ist ja so dass diese
dieser krieg wir verläuft wladimir putin
eben nicht so verläuft wie er sich
vorgestellt hat er wurde mutmaßlich von
seinen fsb leuten ja sehr geblendet
informiert darüber was den zustand
seiner eigenen armee angeht aber auch
was den widerstand hier in der ukraine
angeht und was den willen der menschen
angeht
sozusagen ins russische reich
zurückzukommen wenn wir uns anschauen
das selbst in städten wie herr sohn also
näher richtung russland die menschen auf
die straße gehen mit ukrainischen
flaggen und sagen nein wir wollen das
nicht dann sieht man ja wie schwierig
das für ihn werden würde hier wirklich
das land zu kontrollieren
ich liebe ralf recht es könnte sein dass
sein seine strategie ist so viel zu
bomben- und das sehen wir an den
vergangenen tagen
momentan versucht ja nicht mit truppen
hier rein zu kommen sondern mit
artillerie moerser angriffen und andere
hier für angst und schrecken zu sorgen
und das sieht man jeden morgen oder in
der nacht wir sind gestern nacht von
einer ganz lauten explosion aufgewacht
habe alle wände gewackelt und dann haben
wir den schaden gesehen der sozusagen
angerichtet wurde das passiert in
mariupol noch viel heftiger und in
weiteren städten noch viel heftiger
zurück zu deiner frage was kann man
jetzt tun
ich glaube dass der weg richtig ist der
ukraine zu verhandeln aber gleichzeitig
klar zu machen dass man die position die
wladimir putin zu beginn des krieges
bezogen hat nämlich die militarisierung
neutralität sozusagen der ukraine das
existenzrecht abzusprechen dass das
unmöglich ist natürlich ist das
unmöglich zweitens der westen muss viel
entschlossener wirken und muss in den
sanktionen noch entschlossener wählten
aus meiner sicht und auch im auftreten
gegenüber putin und der frage wie man
mit den oligarchen umgeht und drittens
wir brauchen endlich jemanden der es
schafft die beiden an einen tisch zu
bekommen wladimir putin und selensky wir
haben gesehen wie die mission von
gerhard schröder kolossal gescheitert
ist andere wenig der ukrainische
botschafter hat schröder heute heftig
kritisiert dafür auch aus der ukraine
hören wir dass man gerhard schröder
vorwirft dort eine pr aktion zu seinen
gunsten gestartet zu haben also wenn es
mit gerd schröder nicht geklappt hat
dann frage ich mal in die runde wie wärs
mit angela merkel
vela
spyder angela merkel ja und das haben
wir bei ralf schuler so ein bisschen
herausgehört ich hoffe dass ich das
nicht so richtig verstanden habe also
putin hat angegriffen weil rot-grün in
berlin regieren dann will ich mal gerne
die frage stellen wie wäre es mit angela
merkel gewesen wäre das anders gewesen
und zudem ich werde ihm gar nicht
ausweichen das vielleicht auch so eine
kleine provokation von paul denen ich
seit seiner berichterstattung auf dem
majdan sehr freundschaftlich verbunden
bin das ja auch schon ein paar jahre her
aber ich werde ihm gar nicht ausweichen
paul das kann ja sein dass das die
haltung die duh heute ja auch schon im
bild wiedergegeben ist die haltung der
ukrainischen regierung ist und das muss
man ja auch respektieren ich bin ja auch
bild leser und ich bin ganz kurz
politik oldie sah ich natürlich austria
als politiker gehört ja gleich könnte
man da könnte man davon aus das jahr
doch noch
zum axel springer verlag atlético und
bei politik habe ich eine ganz andere
interpretation dieses treffens gelesen
dass nämlich gerd schröder hier durchaus
in kontakt in engen kontakt war mit der
ukrainischen regierung angesprochen
worden ist ich habe mit ihm darüber
nicht gesprochen also ich weiß nicht
welche version richtig ist ich denke nur
wenn du zwei ganz unterschiedliche
versionen aus dem gleichen verlag kommen
dann sollte sich der leser die eigene
meinung bilden das denn die richtige ist
und was ein bisschen übersteigert oder
vielleicht überinterpretiert ist gab es
dann das treffen aber tripps der ganz
kurzen in der dann muss ich einmal
ja einmal nein ganz kurz weil
bilderseite seine provokation von mir
das stimmt überhaupt nicht es ist alles
geht eigentlich nur um die
nachrichtenlage heute und die
darstellung sozusagen bis der der
nachrichtenlage hat nichts mit meiner
meinung zu tun also wenn du dir diesen
bericht durchliest dann siehst du dort
die zitate des ukrainischen botschaft
dass ich lese gern noch einmal vor die
an deutlichkeit
nichts vermissen lassen das hat ja
nichts mit meiner meinung zu tun sondern
dieser botschafter hat sicher damit
auseinandergesetzt und er sagt zitat
über mittelsmänner wurde die ukrainische
seite aus erster hand informiert über
die ergebnisse der reise von herrn
schröder nach moskau und seines
gesprächs mit putin auch wenn die
hoffnung auf diese persönliche
initiative von herrn schröder von anfang
an jetzt zu klein war ist die
enttäuschung trotzdem groß dass er
wirklich gar nichts konkretes oder
hilfreiches zu berichten hatte dieser
vorstoß entpuppte sich leider gottes als
komplett ergebnislos und wohl auch als
sinnlos um den barbarischen
vernichtungskrieg des putin russlands
gegen die ukrainische zivilbevölkerung
zu stoppen das ist sehr bedauerlich die
ukraine braucht dringend ehrliche
vermittler die uns helfen können das
schlimmste blutvergießen in europa seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg dass putin und
seine treuen schergen tag und nacht
anrichten und das unermessliche leid der
menschen so schnell wie möglich zu
beenden das ist das was ich zitiert habe
da geht es gar nicht um meine meinung
ich muss sagen bei der frage wer diesen
krieg beendet ist mir das völlig egal
wer dort vermittelt und auch wenn ich
bei version aufgrund seines engagements
mit gazprom habe mit gerhard schröder
wenn er doch etwas geschafft hätte hätte
ich ihm nur gratulieren und das ist ja
jetzt momentan offenbar der stand wieder
gegeben von der ukrainischen seite ich
kann das nicht interpretieren ich kann
nur noch mal leider bis jetzt hier nicht
aber können ja jeder nachlesen was ja
zeitgleich heute auch noch mal von
politik über dieses gespräch berichtet
worden ist aus quellen die ich nicht
kenne aber das weiß wohl politiker ein
sehr seriöses auch aus dem
springer-verlag kommendes medium das
offenbar andere quellen hat was kann ich
besser oder schlechter als du nur das
mal dahin gestellt und auch mehr ich
glaube ich haben die anonym das geht ja
auch mal das anrühren oder war das ein
politisches anliegen ich freu mich der
journalist keine aber du hast du hast ja
auch vielleicht eingelesen du hast doch
also erleben die kollegen zu jener nacht
wurde das ist ja ein unterschied ob ich
habe es ja aber ist ja ein unterschied
ob man anonym zitiert oder ob wir es
über ein zitat des ukrainischen
botschaft das spricht ja schon
unterschied wie gesagt ich will mir gar
nicht sagen dass das eine oder das
andere richtig ist nur das ist ja eine
klare aussage da weiß man wer es gesagt
hat und man kennt das zitat und da geht
es ja aber deswegen meine frage wie
kommen wir da jetzt raus also was muss
jetzt passieren also wird gern schröder
noch was erreichen das ist ja eigentlich
gefragt du also mir ist glaube ich nicht
jeden geben nicht wahrscheinlich nicht
aber manchen anderen ist glaube ich
völlig egal wer da was erreicht
hauptsache es wird etwas hat man ob man
nach einem jahr nach einer einem einem
teil von verhandlungen schon von einem
endergebnis reden kann weiß ich auch
nicht vielleicht braucht man mehr zeit
hat keiner in dieser phase aber
vielleicht muss man gucken was da noch
kommt ich weiß es nicht ich will ja auch
mir nicht anmaßen hier irgendwie in die
welt zu setzen die andere frage ist noch
mal zurück wäre mit angela merkel das
nicht passiert denn das lieber reis
schule habe ich so deinen äußerungen so
entnommen das wäre jetzt ein grobes
missverständnis denn die russlandpolitik
von angela merkel ist in meinen augen
auch gescheitert und zwar krachend
gescheitert immer wenn putin irgendwo
gezündelt hat bekam er zur belohnung
irgendein geschenkt damit er wieder
ruhig ist diese logik kann man nicht so
weiterführen schon gar nicht nach einem
angriffskrieg auf ein anderes land das
problem ist dass angela merkel auf eine
ziemlich blauäugige art und weise story
ich möchte keinen airbag lesern immer
die stärke des rechts gepredigt hat und
im gegenteil zum recht des stärkeren was
wir immer vergessen haben das müssen wir
einfach ganz klar sagen auch
gesamtgesellschaftlich übrigens das ist
dass das recht von einer stärke
begleitet und durchgesetzt werden muss
und wer nur recht hat und nicht stark
genug ist das durchzusetzen der verliert
natürlich gegen den stärkeren das haben
wir immer irgendwie unterschätzt und
meine bemerkung zur ampel zielt
eigentlich auch nur darauf hin dass
natürlich die grünen und die spd nicht
das erste sind was ein zum punkte
wehrhaftigkeit ein feld also das ist
natürlich interne flügelkämpfe dass es
debatten geben wird sowas weise ein dass
ich total für 100 milliarden euro ein
war aber ein wenig die gesichter der
grünen durfte man dabei nicht gucken in
meinem bundes osten und auch in der spd
ist dass ich jetzt nicht nur mit eitel
sonnenschein begrüßt worden also das zu
testen und herauszufordern für heute aus
meiner sicht schon sehr kühlem kalkül
scholz hat da mit einem donnerschlag
dagegen gehalten jetzt muss das
natürlich noch umgesetzt werden nachdem
wir nun über angela merkel putin ukraine
russland all diesen wichtigen themen
gesprochen haben kommen bis jetzt zu
einem harten schnitt nach der
unterbrechung vereinsheim verlässt uns
ich glaube auch dass es für dich paul
feig anführen würde jetzt über kroner zu
sprechen würde ich jetzt auf meine
titten danke ich da kann ich nur sagen
seinen abschlussworten das interessante
ist corona ist hier tatsächlich völlig
vergessen ja sie mögen der moz antic
nachvollziehen bei vielen zuschauern
hier in deutschland leider noch nicht
paul wir erleben es immer noch jeden tag
danke dir dass du heute abend wieder
dabei war es und wir sehen uns morgen
haben wieder und wir anderen bleiben und
mit neuen gast sehen wir uns nach der
unterbrechung dankeschön paul bleibt
gesund
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen liebe zuschauer wir
sind zurück nachdem wir die erste hälfte
russland und ukraine gewidmet haben sind
wir jetzt bei den innenpolitischen
themen denn wir wollen über ich würde
sagen den tag der schande sprechen denn
seit heute gilt die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht meine gäste da
wären kurzen gäste weg sie hatten ja
auch mal kurz vorgestellt der ehemalige
regierungssprecher und
kommunikationsprofi nummer eins bilder
anderer neben mir der arzt dr paul
brandenburg der jetzt auch direkt
darüber sprechen wird über die
impfpflicht und auch an meiner seite ja
cdu urgestein jeder kennt ihn als den
kanzler der herzen wolfgang bosbach und
last but not least der chef unserer bild
parlamentsredaktion ralf schuler und
jetzt will ich gar nicht mehr länger
sprechen herr brandenberg ndr
brandenburg legen sie direkt los ja ich
wünschte es wäre hier so wie homs hama
das haus der auch keine berichtete was
krone angeht das ist hier auch nicht
mehr real wäre wir haben heute seit
heute eine einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht das klingt sehr technisch
das klingt sehr sehr indirekt
tatsächlich sind rund jeder siebte
deutsche arbeitnehmer der arbeitsplatz
immer aber ist betroffen von der pflicht
sich gegen coop 19 impfen lassen zu
müssen weil er oder sie mittelbar einen
arbeitsplatz im gesundheitswesen hat und
das ist ein rechter zivilisationsbruch
es ist eine politische gewalttat weil
hier eingegriffen wird in die
körperliche unversehrtheit gesunder
menschen ich als einfacher notarzt darf
patienten nur gegen ihren willen
behandeln unter sehr engen bedingungen
nämlich nur dann wenn ich den
unmittelbaren tod und das unmittelbare
schwere leid abwende und zwar nicht auf
handlungen welcher wahnvorstellungen
eines karl lauterbach der theoretische
möglichkeiten immer wieder herbei
fantasiert sondern ich brauche ganz
konkreten anhalt dass er oder sie sich
selbst schädigen wird weil er klar sagt
ich denke mich umzubringen oder einen
dritten schädigt nur dann darf ich
diesen menschen zwingend behandelt zu
werden und jetzt haben wir substanzen im
umlauf arzneimittel mit schweren
nebenwirkungen die verabreicht werden
zwangsweise respektive wenn ich sie dann
nicht nehmen ich diese indirekte zwangen
dann ist mein arbeitsplatz eben weg die
bewiesenermaßen bewiesenermaßen keinen
dritten schützen können und auch
keinerlei überlastung des
gesundheitssystems ab müssen oder können
das ist ein absoluter kulturbruch es ist
eine vollkommene überschreitung aller
rechtsstaatlichen grenzen und es ist
eine politische gewalt hat dringend
gestoppt werden
eine politische gewalt hat das scheint
mir doch direkt mal zu wolfgang bosbach
tut sich die regierung mit der
einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht
eingefallen oder ist es ev brandenburg
ausgedruckt hat wer eine gewalttat am
bürger
ich glaube nicht dass sich die regierung
damit einen gefallen tut ich würde aber
darum bitten differenziert zu
argumentieren als jemand der zwei mal
geimpft ist und zweimal gemeistert und
sich danach also nach vier impfungen
infiziert hat würde ich trotzdem für das
impfen werben weil ich so gut wie
überhaupt keine symptome hatten aber es
ist ein unterschied ob ich für das
impfen werbe und mich freiwillig impfen
lassen oder ob ich zwangsweise durch
staatliche anordnung geimpft werden muss
es ist noch nicht lange her da hat mich
ein repräsentant eines großen trägers
händeringend darum gebeten dass die
impfpflicht nicht kommt weil er
befürchtet dass es kontraproduktiv sein
könnte denn sie betrifft ja nur menschen
die sich nicht freiwillig lassen ich
füge hinzu wenn wir eine sterile
immunität garantieren könnten würde ich
das anders sehen aber warum musste ich
in quarantäne als jemand der firma
geimpft worden ist doch offensichtlich
weil ich virus tiger war und andere
hätte infizieren können es stimmt also
nicht dass diejenigen die geimpft sind
so geschützt sind dass sie andere nicht
infizieren können wir haben mit der
impfpflicht die pocken ja die haben wir
nun wirklich das wird der grund beim
besser wissen als ich brauch das jetzt
mal kühn weltweit ausgerottet aber wir
haben hier keine oder leider noch keinen
impfstoff mit dem wir eine sterile
immunität garantieren könne es ist noch
nicht lange her
hat ersparen in seiner rolle als
gesundheitsminister gesagt ich
garantiere es wird keine impfpflicht
geben auch lauterbach selber war einmal
kritiker der impfpflicht
ich kann mir das nur so vorstellen dass
so eine art vorratsbeschluss gefasst
wird für möglicherweise eine welle die
im winter kommen könnte schloss als von
mir das wesentliche argument seit zwei
jahren war immer keine überlastung
unseres gesundheitssystems warum jeder
der ernsthaft erkrankt ist und
medizinischer behandlung braucht muss
auch behandelt werden können wir sind
gott sei dank trotz sehr hohe inzidenz
sind wir meilenweit von einer
überlastung unseres gesundheitssystems
entfernt also dieses argument fällt weg
als jurist bin ich natürlich gespannt
wie karlsruhe entscheiden er bleibt
sicher ist darüber in streit schlimmer
noch sie haben ja das entscheidende
gesagt nicht die freiwilligkeit ist das
absolute stichwort das ist völlig
richtig jeder der das freiwillig möchte
der soll das recht haben und die
möglichkeit sich behandeln zu lassen mit
diesem impfstoff das ist vollkommen klar
aber das zweite was sie sagt ist ja der
punkt nicht die überlastung des
gesundheitssystem hat ist so niemals
gegeben nicht dieser herr lauterbach hat
eine unendliche kette von lügen
aufgetischt diese zeitung dieser verlag
hat ja viele davon entfernt und immer
wieder auch betitelt dieser mann ist ein
berufsmäßiger lügner und hetzer
verbreitet absolute lügen über eine
angebliche intensivbetten knappheiten
nicht über schreckliche wirkung auf
junge eltern kinder würden jetzt die die
ihre eltern verlieren da zeichnet immer
wieder schlimmste horror szenarien
nichts davon war real diese lügen sind
alle aufgeflogen und die krönung des
ganzen erleben wir jetzt gerade wenn man
mal schaut unser deutsches
gesundheitssystem kostet im jahr rund
300 milliarden euro das ist eine
unglaubliche summe rund 11 prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes das argument war
immer wir haben das geld nicht dieses
gesundheitssystem zu retten nun ist mit
einem fingerschnipsen genau diese summe
von 300 milliarden ja aufgetaucht für
neue waffen für die bundeswehr für
energie politische ideologien der damen
und herren dort in rot grün aber das
gesundheitssystem konnte angeblich nur
gerettet werden mit dieser impfung die
ja medizinisch versorgt sagen wir es
ganz ehrlich es tut mir leid auch wenn
sie gewusst und geimpft bewusst sind
nach der impfung also das ganze ist ein
fürchterliches lügengebäude ist gibt
keine überlastung abzuwenden und selbst
wenn hätte man wohl offenbar auch noch
geld gehabt das zu tun das ist eine
katastrophe fehler darf man daran und
wollten eine
zwischenfrage nur das ist das ist ein
wichtiger punkt das hat die
bundesregierung selbst eingeräumt
bundesweit aber hat es denn nicht
tatsächlich kliniken gegeben die
überlastet waren mit der folge dass
patienten abgewiesen werden mussten
solche für planbare operationen oder das
waren andere kliniken um deren aufnahme
gebeten hat so dass es eine partielle
völlig richtig aber es macht aber da
muss man auch wieder sagen das ist in
der intensivmedizin leider tägliches
geschäft immer zu den erkältungswelle zu
den grippewellen zu den saisonalen
häufung von infektionen haben wir diese
überlastung ich als notarzt bin im
bereich berlin-brandenburg häufig damit
beschäftigt gewesen so genannte sekundär
verlegung zu machen das ist der
technische terminus dafür wenn so eine
klinik voll ist und die patienten
verlegen müssen das ist relativ normal
erklärt sich durch das bezahlungssystem
im gesundheitswesen man kann vereinfacht
sagen eine intensivstation muss immer
voll sein damit sie sich trägt so etwas
wie eine freie intensivstation gibt es
nicht ansonsten fällt sie weg da ist
also immer höchstens ein oder zwei
betten sind da frei oder werden dafür
verwendet so ist das system aufgebaut
das ist vollkommen normal anders herum
gesagt unsere intensivstation sind seit
vielen jahren überlastet das personal
ist stark überlastet das ist dabei alles
alt und einer der hauptverantwortlichen
täter für diese chronische überlastung
ist heute gesundheitsminister der hat
dieses system auf und dieses die ag
system und ein personal system ein
arbeitsteam ein schichtsystem was die
menschen wirklich auf dem knochen
bremsen lässt und was dafür sorgt dass
wir rekrutierungsprobleme haben
insbesondere bei der pflege also die
überlastung ist real da hat auch crooner
mit reingespielt aber corona war ihnen
nicht kausal es war eine überlastung mit
corona aber nicht eine überlastung
ankommen ich bin ja auch eine die oft
und gerne karl lauterbach kritisiert hat
hier auch in der sendung ich muss sagen
er ist aber immer wieder gekommen also
egal was wir machen es auch gegen kommen
hat sich dem dialog gestellt das hat mir
schon respekt abverlangt wer sind meine
frage an dich greift darf man karl
lauterbach als hetzer bezeichnen wie es
dr brandenburger ja ich wäre mit dem mit
dem wort weil er ja ohnehin von vielen
inflationär verwendet wird etwas
sparsamer
auch franz müntefering hat vor jahren
schon mal gesagt es sei ziemlich unfair
politiker immer an ihren worten von
gestern zu messen
ja gut
das würde das problem dass ich einfach
sehr ist die logische lücke die sich
immer mehr menschen
erschließt andererseits dürfen wir auch
nicht vergessen 58 prozent sagen in
unserer letzten umfrage vom letzten
wochenende immer noch sie sind für eine
impfpflicht unter anderem weil sie
selbst geimpft sind und das doof finden
dass andere es nicht sind dem kann man
aber natürlich entgegen halten wenn wir
täglich mehr als 100.000 infizierte
haben dann ist irgendwann die impflücken
aufgebraucht das heißt also wenn es nur
um diejenigen gene aus denen die
infektionen sich speiste die nicht
geimpft sind dann werden die nach einer
woche alle krank gewesen das problem ist
tatsächlich bücher postbank vielfach
geimpft und und schon wieder in
quarantäne
die impfung ist eine normale medizin sie
ist eine art biologisches pflaster sie
wirkt nicht als das wo wir wie wir
früher impfungen definiert haben kann
ist willkommen nachdem mehr einsatz nach
zu hören dr brand es gibt ja auch sie
sind mediziner es gibt viel kritik von
medizinern an den an den maßnahmen und
ganz verrückt ist was ich hier gefunden
habe aus den reihen des
gesundheitsministeriums gibt es vom 22
februar eine ein factsheet fragen und
antworten eben zu dieser einrichtung
bezogenen impfprävention impfpflicht und
das steht um eigentlich zitiert um eine
eintragung und weiterverbreitung des
virus in diesem setting es eben bei den
pflegepersonal zu vermeiden ist es
unerlässlich dass das dort tätige
personal vollständig geimpft ist halb
kurz darauf hingewiesen wir haben jeden
tag mehr als 100.000 200.000 260.000
infizierte also die impfung und dazu
komme gleich schützt nicht wir brauchen
ja noch zeit für dein thema bildung ist
übrigens einer der hart gegen mich immer
diskutiert hat wenn ich gegen die
impfpflicht weil du warst dafür wir
haben uns oft gestritten der
freundschaft außerhalb der kulissen hat
es keinen abbruch getan aber dann kommen
wir auch zu dem thema wie du jetzt ja
dass das hat tatsächlich sich gewandelt
als ich dann einmal drosten ist ja sehr
vorsichtig damit muss man sehr
vorsichtig sein mit kritik als er gesagt
hat also das beste der beste schutz ist
drei mal geimpft und in entsprechende
postert und dann noch mal dreifach
infiziert möglichst schwer und dann ist
man relativ geschützt für mehrere jahre
das waren seine worte und da habe ich
angefangen nachzudenken ich war bei am
wochenende in österreich und über nacht
ist unser nachbar ein neues land
geworden ohne masken pflicht nämlich
nirgendwo nur noch im einzelhandel die
menschen sind fröhlich einander
zugewandt und auch mit der impfpflicht
haben die österreicher schluss gemacht
entgegen früherer vorhaben weil die
politiker in wien nämlich gemerkt haben
verstand namen des teppichs zur
prävention nicht mehr allgemein
durchsetzbar ist das eine impfpflicht
auch nicht durchzusetzen ist bei uns an
zwar unsere ampelkoalition ihre doch
diesen mut das einzugestehen hat
eigentlich nur mister klartext im
bundestag geben kein bosbach hier eben
wolfgang kubicki der rest von kubicas
kollegen versucht zu verschleppen was
gar nicht mehr zu retten ist nämlich die
impfpflicht am donnerstag soll es da die
es beratung geben im bundestag und einer
impfpflicht die auch nach meiner festen
überzeugung nicht mehr kommen wird denn
die grundannahme für die impfpflicht
haben darüber gesprochen wie stimmt
nämlich nicht mehr dass eine impfung
schützt vor einer infektion geschützt
mich das glaube ich bei einem schweren
verlauf aber nicht vor einer infektion
das heißt eine impfpflicht kann nur
kommen wenn sie wirklich schützt das tut
sie nicht ich finde die politiker
sollten den mut haben endlich
abzuschwören donnerstag ist dafür ein
guter
da lassen wir doch direkt sie darauf
antworten herr dr paar bränden wurde er
an der trifft den nagel auf den kopf
wenn ich sehe mich an ganz neuen
funktionen dass ich an dem
regierungssprecher zu bestimmen muss das
ist genauso ihren heiligen
regierungssprecher hat man das wirklich
jemals ablegt aber ja er kann nur
zustimmen also die frage ist aber und
das ist der kernpunkt glaube ich macht
euch ehrlich und da liegt das problem
diese regierungen auch die
vorgängerregierung haben ja mit dieser
mit dieser serie von lügen mit diesen
harten eingriffen in das in die
gesundheit in das leben der bürger so
viel vertrauen verspielt ein wolfgang
bosbach selbst ihr und bringt es auf den
punkt und sagte aber ich habe das doch
getan ich habe mich behandeln lassen ich
habe dieses risiko in kauf genommen was
ist denn jetzt mit mir ich bin schwer
getäuscht worden und dieses vertrauen
was da zerstört wurde das ist unser
eigentliches problem wir sehen welche
spaltung ist in der gesellschaft
gebracht hat wir sehen einen wirklich
aus meiner sicht nie dagewesenen
vertrauensverlust in die regierung wir
haben berufsmäßige lügner und
hochstapler ja in vielfachen funktion
installiert wird dass eine frau berbalk
ist die wieder ihr lebenslauf
zusammengeschustert und jetzt kommt so
etwas auch noch ein eingriff der
eingriff ins leben ich fürchte es reicht
nicht einfach nur damit dass man jetzt
sagt es tut uns leid nicht wir haben das
gewaltverbrechen versucht jetzt lassen
wir es sein und gehen einen schritt
zurück es brauchte einen neuaufbau an
vertrauen ich zweifel daran dass das
einfach durch ein unterlassen dieser
impfpflicht jetzt geschieht ich glaube
auch wieder anders wird nicht zu dieser
impfpflicht kommen ich glaube aber es
wird in diesen mechanismus danach zu
ähnlichen versuchen in zukunft kommen
und das müssen wir ausschließen wir
brauchen eine aufarbeitung dieser
vorgänge ich glaube das war jetzt kein
werbeblock für die ampel wenn man uns
das angucken hat die ampel aber auch für
die impfpflicht weder für die generelle
noch für die einrichtungs bezogene die
ist nun durch weil man tatkraft
signalisieren wollte aber für die für
die allgemeine impfpflicht gar keine
mehrheit das ist schon interessant weder
fdp noch bei den grünen auch in der spd
gibt es keine eigene mehrheit und das
wird so eine art parlamentarisches motto
was wir haben donnerstag sehen das heißt
man wird verschiedene entwürfe
impfpflicht mit 18 impfung ab 50 durch
stimmen und dann wird man gucken ob sich
nach dem durchfallen des ersten genügend
leute dann auf das kleinere übel den
nächsten finden wenn das nicht der fall
ist fällt am ende alles durch und auch
der vorschlag der union der ist ja aus
meiner sicht noch ein bisschen der rest
plausibelste wenn man einen
vorratsbeschluss wenn erst mal so kommen
sollte dann könnten wir eine impfpflicht
anschalten das problem ist man müsste
man schlägt beschließt doch eine leere
hülle also wenn es eine krankheits lage
gibt und dann gibt es auch noch einen
impfstoff wo eine impfpflicht wichtig
wäre dann könnten wir sie zur pflicht
machen ja gut das kann der bundestag
aber jederzeit es kann jederzeit eine
sondersitzung einberufen werden
eigentlich ist das dem 1 1 aus flucht
angebot an die ampel die keine eigene
mehrheit hat und der impfgegner kubicki
hat mehrere stapel von autogrammkarten
auf seinem schreibtisch liegen die pro
woche verschickt einfach weil die leute
das richtig toll finden der schüler der
impfgegner kubicki hat dann doch dafür
gestimmt nicht mit fraktions rationale
und der disziplin die die einigung ja
aber ich fürchte auch damit hat er seine
glaubwürdigkeit verspielt bei denjenigen
die sagen da hättest mal ernsthafte
gegen vergeben das nämlich ist aber viel
überzeugung im abo league das ist jetzt
aber dass da sagen sie wieder als macht
pragmatiker das will ich ihnen nicht
nachsehen aber ich denke dass das
vertrauen bei den bürgern nur dann
wieder hergestellt werden kann wenn
diese verhaltensmuster mal durchbrochen
wir haben nun den menschen das geht ja
auch erkenntnis dass max in der politik
muss man ja auch sehen es gab
situationen wo auch wirklich breite
teile der bevölkerung höchst besorgt
gewesen sind und auch jetzt sind ja noch
viele der ansicht egal hauptsache wir
tun irgendwas da draußen ist eine große
erfahrung denn warum denn das ist doch
gerade die frage ist vielen doch alles
an mit einer bundeskanzlerin merkel die
beim aufkommen dieses virus sofort einen
ihrer seltenen fernseh auftritte
hingelegt hat und sofort den menschen
versprach wir werden wirklich alles tun
jedes geld ausgeben um jeden toten her
immerhin sei es war nicht so weit ist es
war sehr schnell und die menschen haben
systematisch angst gemacht bekommen das
war ja wirklich dass das spiel der
politik und jetzt klammern sie sich
sogar an masken im freien nicht erleben
jetzt wie ein bundesland nach dem
anderen ankündigt wir halten die maske
draußen ist die kunden sehen ist ein
wunderbares gefühl beim tc am anfang ich
dachte immer wo ist ihr jetzt mal eine
maus gewicht mal vom tisch abstand und
so und man hat das ganz verlangt aber es
macht die menschen wirklich freier und
dann besser miteinander wenn nur ein
sachen zu den impfungen sagen die
politik hat auch nie so kommuniziert
dass ihr gesagt hat wir haben uns auch
mal geirrt was ist uns den vermittelt
wird eine moderne reicht zwei impfungen
sind besser dann kam auf einmal
der booster der unbedingt sein aber am
anfang nie vermittelt worden ist wenn
mir gesagt worden ist mit 2 mit zwei
impfungen bist du dein leben lang
geschützt da hat sich keiner hingestellt
und gesagt wir haben uns gehört du
brauchst noch den booster bis hin zu ich
wiederhole mich an drosten drei
impfungen booster drei mal infiziert
dann wahrscheinlich auf mehrere jahre
gut geschützt wenn die infektion
möglichst schwer war wir sind all
gestartet von einer impfung
beziehungsweise zwei impfungen sind da
jetzt angekommen aber nirgendwo entlang
des weges hatte ich ja irgend jemanden
gehört gesagt hat okay wenn man das
früher anders gesagt haben sich aber
neue erkenntnisse gegeben und das ist
auch ein großer großer
vertrauensverluste sich dadurch eben mit
manifestiert in solchen eben anders es
ist ja in der medizin banal als kennt
man das nicht ein patient will seinem
arzt vertrauen so will ja auch die
bevölkerung ganz allgemein dass die
regierung sie schützt wenn ich als arzt
einen offenkundigen fehler mache und
mein patient spürt das ja der merkt er
lief etwas mehr richtig wird meistens
spürt dass doch so schlimm sind die
fehler medizin meist nicht jeder student
lernt gibt diesen fehler zu geht zum
patienten gesteht dass das ein in der
realität lernst du dann schnell vorsicht
die versicherung legte der hersteller du
kannst nicht einfach ein fehler
der politik ein gutes schloss
in die politik und auch fehler
einzugestehen sollten die politiker
machen schön aber wir sind morgen wieder
für sie da und 20.15 cis